quand le corps de grégory villemin 4 ans
est repêché dans la vologne le 16
octobre 1984
personne n'imagine le foll emballement
médiatico judiciaire qui s'ensuivra
cette lettre attribuée aux corbeaux
focalise toutes les enquêtes
c'est la clé de voûte de toute l'affairé
aurait sans l affaire et gorille pendant
des dd direction complètement différente
une étude graphologique et surtout les
accusations de muriel bolle sa
belle-soeur qui finira par se rétracter
désigne bernard laroche le beau frère de
jean marie villemin comme le coupable
il est mis en examen par le juge lambert
puis innocenté persuadé de sa
culpabilité jean marie villemin
l'abattra d'un coup de fusil le 29 mars
1985 puis c'est au tour de christine
villemin d'être accusé de l'assassinât
de son fils sur la foi de trois
témoignages de collègues de travail
devant l'absence d'éléments tangibles
elle bénéficie d'un non lieu le 3
février 1993
la même année jean marie villemin est
condamné à cinq ans de prison pour
l'assassinât de bernard laroche en 2000
l'enquêté ouverte sur la base de
l'analyse adn de la salive sur le timbre
l'échantillon s'avère inexploitables la
cour d'appel de dijon clôt
définitivement l'instruction de la
sphère puis l'arrêt ouvre en 2009 de
nouvelles analyses sur les scellés
notamment les cordelettes met en
évidence des traces d'adn mais aucune ne
correspond à celle des protagonistes de
la faire
[Musique]
en 2012 l'analyse de la voix numérisée
du corbeau n'aboutit elle à aucun
résultat tangible
les progrès de la science ne permettent
pas d'en apprendre davantage les trois
arrestations de ce jour permettront
peut-être de connaître enfin la vérité
sur cet assassinat
trente deux ans après les faits